what Ariana Grande's friends really
think of her quickie engagement +
Beyonce and jay-z is not safe for work
pics and could oprah team up with the
ocean's 8 cast for a sequel hello Lolo
guys I am back from New York City I
gotta tell you I have way too much fun
covering the Tonys red carpet for CBS
now if you watched our Facebook live
from the Tonys thank you so much it is
good to be back and while I was gone
ariana grande and Pete Davidson got
engaged I need to hear initial reactions
right now go because I was on the plane
I read that and I was like huh I mean
Ari and Pete wasted no time getting
engaged huh and I wasn't the only one
who surprised by how quickly this
happened American Idols Katy Turner
tweeted if Ariana and Pete can get
engaged after a few weeks of dating I
can fall in love with a hot grocery
store cashier in one day you know what
you better preach Katy and my Starbucks
barista crush yeah you're about to get a
flashmob proposal for me this week right
so how did the newly engaged couple
celebrate well with the trip to
Disneyland
just hours after et learned Pete popped
the question and what better place to
celebrate an engagement than the
happiest place on earth am i right a
source close to the SNL cast member
tells et though Ariana and Pete's
whirlwind romance is fueled strongly by
passion and emotion adding quote Pete
creates this intense relationship that
is moving a million miles a minute
yeah well that speed apparently has some
of Ariana's friends concerned though a
source telling et quote Ariana gets so
excited about an idea and so set on
making it happen that she doesn't always
think it through we fear it was so
spontaneous it might not last well damn
still the couple could keep going at the
same pace our source says Ariana has
always dreamt of a winter wonderland
wedding which might mean Pete and Ari
will see I do before the end of the year
and I thought Pete tattooing her
initials on his thumb last week was
intense clearly things are moving fast
but you know they say when you know you
know and I know I'm probably gonna be
alone forever so that's cool Congrats
Pete and Ariana happy for you right well
speaking of actual true love Beyonce and
jay-z have no problem baring their souls
and the
intimate details of their relationship
in their music but now they're on the
run and showing much more that's right
these racy photos went viral as soon as
concert goers got their hands on the
couple's on the run to tour booked the
photos include a barely dressed B and
jay-z in bed cuddling in another and
Beyonce even bears her backside up in
this one and that's how the cars got
their groove back am i right source
tells et this intimate look inside their
world is because Beyonce and jay-z want
to let fans into their lives on their
own terms
now the duo performed in Scotland over
the weekend and their next show is
tomorrow night in England on roomie and
sirs / birthday hey not a bad way to
celebrate meanwhile was a celebration
for the ladies of oceans 8 the summer
caper is the number one movie in the box
office and Sandy Bullock said a sequel
depends on how well it's received so
Bullock you got a winner and we want
another and we're hearing y'all want
oprah to join the squad
well et's the shelter nerd caught up
with lady Oh on the pink carpet at the
premiere of her new summer series love
is to find out if yeah that was just
with all the ladies from ocean's 8 at
their premiere this we seen it so good
you're gonna love it
but if they do in oceans 9 they all said
they would like you to be the one to
join them I mean I'm in ladies they
already had like the story like the
biggest oceans ever with all of them
combined hello
such a fun show a me too me too very
have it she's in but something tells me
she's a Supes busy so if you guys could
cast anyone up in a potential oceans 9
film who would it be let us know in the
comments section all right well this was
fun
went by real fast today but time to go
and I'll see you guys smile
[Music]